dr anthony fauci was interviewed on 60
minutes last night he's the top
infectious disease doctor in the country
one of the top
and most trusted public health officials
in the country
and it's it's both interesting and
really depressing and tough to watch i
want to go through a few of the things
that dr fauci said it was a wide-ranging
interview
this was an interesting moment dr fauci
was asked
whether he was surprised that donald
trump personally got coronavirus listen
to what dr
fauci said were you surprised that
president trump got sick
absolutely not i was worried that he was
going to get sick when i saw him
in a completely precarious situation
of crowded no separation
between people and almost nobody wearing
a mask
when i saw that on tv i said
oh my goodness nothing good can come out
of that
that's got to be a problem and then sure
enough it turned out to be a super
spreader event
so fauci not only not surprised that
donald trump got coronavirus but clearly
and unequivocally pointing out
the white house event for the nomination
of amy coney barrett
that was a super spreader event we know
just of people
affiliated with trump never mind randos
in the audience
chris christie kellyanne conway the
president of notre dame
trump others caught covid probably
at that event and dr fauci he seems to
just be sick of it at this point and
you'll see why in a moment
just telling it like it is in this next
clip and this is part of what fauci is
sick of
you will see dr fauci going for a walk
now with armed security
once an avid runner at 79 dr fauci now
power walks
flanked by federal agents what's that
all about
that's sad the very fact that a public
health
message to save lives
triggers such venom and animosity to me
that it results in real incredible
threats to my life and my safety
but it bothers me less than the hassling
of my wife and my children they've been
threatened
yeah i mean like give me a break have
there been death threats against you and
your family
well all of you you're not just me but
again harassment against the rest of the
family
what is wrong with this country we have
a country where i'm not going to say
half
but 20 25 30
of the country is arguably
institutionalizable
if that's a word and it's not but you
understand what it means
uh in their disconnect from reality and
they're backwards i mean it's directly
it's it's to call it anti-social
behavior
it understates what it actually is
threats to dr
fauci and his wife and his daughters are
there leading public health officials in
any other country
put in this degree of danger where they
need full-time
armed security we are backwards here
it's shameful it's embarrassing the
the english language almost lacks in its
ability to characterize this for what it
is
and um what when you look at what's
going on in other countries
you're starting to see leaders of
both public health and political leaders
in other countries not even tolerate
the nonsense we have interesting clips
over the last couple of weeks from
uh ireland from new zealand australia
and other places
in this country the president is
actually
fomenting this type of stuff against dr
fauci
um very interestingly one of the big
conspiracies or
pejoratives applied to dr fauci and joe
biden is they want to lock down
everything forever
they're they're just about lockdowns
kill the economy lock it all down
even dr fauci himself says
he would be very hesitant to recommend
a national lockdown and this is
important
because trump and the right have been
caricaturing him
as wanting lockdowns forever all the
time fauci says quite simply here
it's a last resort it's not what i want
how bad would things have to get for you
to advocate a national lockdown they'd
have to get really really bad
first of all the country is fatigued
with restrictions so we want to use
public health
measures not to get in the way
of opening the economy but to being a
safe gateway to opening the economy so
instead of
having an opposition open up the economy
get jobs back or shut down no
put shutdown away and say we're going to
use public health measures
to help us safely get to where we want
to go
and of course this is the problem half
the country is so busy saying
we won't lock down which fauci isn't
suggesting
that they're ignoring the reality of the
pandemic they're ignoring the things
they can be doing to prevent spread
including not having big parties and
events particularly indoors
masks lots of other measures but the
point is
this is not a guy itching to lock down
the country and why would anyone be
itching to lock down the country it's
ridiculous
really important question that came up
has the white house been controlling
when and where dr fauci can speak to the
media there have been rumors that dr
fauci has not been allowed to do certain
shows and fauci says yeah they have been
limiting me take a look
during this pandemic has the white house
been controlling when you can speak
with the media you know i think you'd
have to be honest to say yes
uh i certainly have not been
allowed to go on many many many shows
that have
asked for me one of the most trusted
voices in america and yet
you're not there you're not allowed to
talk with us so can you understand the
frustration that maybe there's been a
restriction
on the flow of information on
transparency you know i think there has
been a restriction john but
but it doesn't it isn't consistent
the most trusted public official on the
topic of coronavirus according to
polling
every poll fouchy the most trusted on
the issue of coronavirus
blocked from speaking to people blocked
from appearing on shows
it's a sick country and in fact
trump rep you might remember this trump
replaced fauci
at his public events with this doctor
named scott atlas who's a
neuroradiologist now understand
neuroradiology is a specialty of
radiology what is a radiologist a
radiologist is a doctor
who sits in a room and i'm not demeaning
what radiologists do i'm just telling
you
they don't know about pandemics and
infectious disease a
much like you wouldn't go to a
podiatrist to deal with coronavirus you
wouldn't go to a neuroradiologist
radiologists look at x-rays mris
ct scans and other imaging to diagnose
conditions when i went in for my
appendectomy
they did a ct scan it was sent to a
radiologist who looked at the scan and
said
appendicitis i'll take 600 thank you
very much
that is what they do neuroradiology is a
subspecialty someone who looks at brain
spine and neck images why is that person
the most prominent medical figure around
donald trump
for dealing with a pandemic because he
says what trump wants him to say
masks don't really work he deleted that
tweet
let's look at herd immunity let's open
everything
nearly a hundred stanford immunologists
uh signed a letter
calling out this guy and this is who
trump promotes
as dr fauci is blocked from being on
shows
and needs armed security to go for a
walk with his wife
there has to be some reckoning for this
doesn't there does i get i mean
i guess the reckoning is tons of people
are getting sick and dying relative to
other countries but
the the consequences should affect the
people who ran the policy
not innocent people who through this
failed policy
are catching the virus and dying it's
it's absolutely disgusting and it only
reinforces and highlights underlines the
urgency of removing joe biden
i'm sorry removing donald trump and
removing these doctors and putting in
joe biden i voted this weekend
uh you can find video of me voting all
perfectly beautiful legal video uh on my
instagram
at david.pakman let me know if you voted
either there or you can find me on
twitter at dpakman
one of our sponsors today is hydrant and
they're giving my audience 25
off your first order hydrant has been
great for me
it's this delicious electrolyte powder
made with real fruit juice
you mix it into water for great tasting
rehydration
with low sugar packed with electrolytes
but way more cost effective than those
high sugar sports drinks
comes in flavors like lime fruit punch
orange mango
they have no sugar varieties which come
in lemonade and pink grapefruit
they also have a new product line called
immunity
which adds vitamins b c and d and they
have a version with caffeine
if you're looking for that type of boost
staying hydrated helps my focus
and keeps my energy up and hydrant has
been a great way for me to do that as
part of my daily routine
they have a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
off your first order when you go to
drink hydrant dot com
slash pacman or just enter the code
pacman at checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video